- Charles Hamelin!
- Celui qu'on appelle
la locomotive de Sainte-Julie
entre en gare.
- Le tout pour le tout
jusqu'à la toute fin!
- Charles Hamelin couronne
une immense carrière
devant sa foule, sa famille,
et s'offre un dernier tour
de piste avec sa fille.
CHARLES HAMELIN, médaillé
de bronze, relais masculin
- Je le voulais, ce tour-là,
puis juste de l'avoir eue
avec moi, qu'elle ait pu voir
un peu c'est quoi ma vision
de la chose sur la glace,
même si elle a pas conscience
de ce qui s'est passé,
elle va avoir beaucoup
de beaux souvenirs de ça.
Puis, on aura plein de photos
à lui montrer de la dernière
course de papa.
GENEVIÈVE TARDIF,
conjointe de Charles Hamelin
- Que Violette soit là pour voir
son papa, c'était juste
la plus belle chose au monde.
C'est ça qu'il voulait,
puis ça s'est réalisé.
- 38e fois en carrière, médaillé
au Championnat du monde :
Charles Hamelin!
- Le champion olympique met
un point d'orgue à son aventure
sportive en décrochant un 38e
podium : le bronze au relais
masculin. Un dernier succès dont
il a savouré chaque seconde et
qui s'ajoute aux 150 médailles
de Coupe du monde et
aux 6 podiums olym
Le palmarès est exceptionnel,
mais pour Charles
le plaisir a primé sur tout.
- Je voulais être fier de ça,
être fier de... de tout
l'acharnement que j'ai eu et le
plaisir que j'ai e cet
acharnement-là. Puis, tu sais,
je l'ai expliqué beaucoup dans
ma carrière, j'ai eu mal aux
jambes beaucoup, et j'ai aimé
avoir maes. C'est
un peu ça, le résumé. Tu sais,
c'est... Même si ça faisait
toujours mal, bien, j'ai aimé
avoir mal. Ha! ha! ha!
- Charles Hamelin passe le
flambeau à une équipe canadienne
bourrée de talent qui a remporté
huit médailles à ces derniers
Mondiaux et qui compte désormais
de vice-champions du monde :
Kim Boutin et Pascal Dion,
deux athlètes inspirés.
PASCAL DION, vice-champion
du monde, Championnats du monde
- Le travail à l'entraînement,
le travail dans les
compétitions, c'est ce qui fait
qu'il a été un champion.
Puis, je pense qu'on a
tellement à retenir de ça.
KIM BOUTIN, vice-championne
du monde, Championnats du monde
- Ça a été une idole.
Puis, réellement,
cette personne-là qui m'a
permis de croire en ce que
je voulais réaliser,
écrire ma propre histoire.
- Trois, deux, un,ti!
- Celui qui aura bientôt 38 ans
quitte l'âme en paix et avec
la tête pleine de projets.
Il se marie en juin et compte
partager son amour pour le patin
avec les plus jeunes.
- Ce qui s'en vient, c'est super
beau aussi. Puis, là, vous le
voyez, les gens applaudissent,
puis... C'est juste beaude voirt
fière de Charles et de tout
ce qu'il a accompli.
- Charles Hamelin!
- Hamelin aura inspiré toute
une génération de patineurs.
Et ce n'est pas terminé.
Ici Diane Sauvé,
Radio-Canada, Mon